I turn right now to the phone lines and
I guess that the front end of a home and
home because as soon as this show is
over I'm sticking around to have a
conversation for his program ferdi up
close parenthetical from a distance NBC
and golf channel analyst right here on
the Rich Eisen show once again David
Feherty how are you David I'm doing fine
given the circumstances rich I know
there's everybody fun of your family
everybody good but she has everybody
fine I have a son who is a correctional
officer who is volunteered to be in the
overt nineteen part of the prison so
that's a little bit of a worry but you
know everybody fine okay is there
anything you you'd be up for sharing on
that again I don't want to press too
much on anything in their personal front
but that is something that we're hearing
quite a bit about our correctional
facilities being at the forefront of
right in the middle of this whole thing
David yeah they are
they've been fortunate in Rory's
establishment they're in Denton County
and in Texas and they only have one
inmate at the minute but you're right
you know and in prisons around the
country it's been a huge problem so I
mean it's a worry there's no for any
parent would worry about that
sure and then obviously when what what
you're doing and what we're attempting
to do every day is to take people's
minds off things and and continue to
talk are you hearing anything about when
you think that the golf world might
return I know we've got that exciting
Tiger Phil Peyton Manning Tiger and Tom
Brady match coming soon but are you what
are you hearing about potentially the
the return of of the tour well I
understand they're they're gonna play
the colonial tournament in Fort Worth
without spectators and that's I think
June the sixth and I want to say I want
to be planted by spectators
it's like having cornflakes without milk
i I don't know you know I I think you
know I had an idea about the state you
know the way to get a laugh track
share on on a set culture you know could
we pipe in applause or something like
that I don't know
I mean we could we mean we could we
could be the ones that give the golf
club to David you know yeah that's right
yeah exactly we could do that we could
Marilyn yeah yeah I mean I think you
know to give it some sort of a sale of
you know as ridiculous as it might sound
I think it would sound better so you
know I I know that though that that you
know tiger and Phil and and Brady and
Peyton Manning that that's gonna go off
without any fans either but it's just
for guys I guess going around and I
guess you could be socially distant and
all that I I just can't wait I mean I I
do hope this doesn't get pulled off in
June and and then what the Masters may
look like in the fall I mean it's just
really all over the map I just want to
give you the floor and and and what you
think this golf season could look like
David well I mean first of all you know
that Tiger has been socially destined
for the last 25 years there's not much
there's not much difference there I mean
that'll be fun to see that much but golf
is is the ideal sport for social
distancing if you think about it I mean
the chances of two players hit anywhere
near each other or remote unless you're
at the you know the top end of the game
so I mean the golf course is here and
Texas are open or opening and you know
people are playing the card situation is
you know there's a lot of golf courses
are open for walking or if you have your
own cart you can use it that kind of
thing but the golf season I mean it's
interesting to me how they're going to
either going to cover it with
overlapping with football and and every
other sports you know is Jimmy Nance is
he going to be at the at the Masters or
is he going to be doing football I think
I think you can bet that he'll be there
a master someday I think did we ask him
that question
Chris recon it we did kind of we did
he's going to choose golf yeah oh yeah
yeah that's interesting yeah he pretty
much day let's all who's gonna cover
what and when are they going to cover it
and and are they gonna you know do the
timing up at the minister it's or
there's a lot of moving parts to get in
there
right place I wouldn't like to be in
charge abut us for sure David Feherty
host of Faraday up close from a distance
which you can catch again on Golf
Channel's YouTube page new interviews
being added weekly I'm appreciative of
the invitation to appear on this and
I'll be recording that later on with you
sir
what what are what are the topics you
talk about with people I get that
question all the times what do you talk
about when there's no actual live sports
so I'll give you the that's very same
question David yeah well it's more of a
personal sort of a thing you know I mean
how are you dealing with this this
situation you know what are you doing
with me like what did you do yesterday
you know and get into a little
background
you know people as well I've been doing
some terrifying research on you fine
research okay is there anything that can
help you with and is this a
pre-interview potentially yeah well
David I screamed at my kids for three
hours trying to win father of the year
then they played video poker with my
buddies in a zoom last night for about
four and a half hours and that was my
day after doing the Rich Eisen show a TV
radio show I've been sort of a half
man/half mattress you know are curled up
together for much of the day and he
caught a squirrel which was the
highlight of my wake the squirrel a
couple of days ago which was just a
miracle
there's no kidding that's the highlight
of your week that's where you you take a
picture or something like that David oh
yeah absolutely yeah I mean you've
gotten to meet some obviously
interesting guests Smoltz now Smoltz is
busy scratch David at one stage he was I
think he was in the Plus peckers maybe
as low as plus four I can't even imagine
I mean just some basic John John is a
terrific player I mean really is he the
best of the celebrity players no
question or husband you know that but
you know the game is it's always amazed
me just how many people love this game
of well I mean I've got
today a little later I've got Michelle
Wie which I'm recording and George Lopez
so I mean it's a kind of a broad
brushstroke
you know people that that are coming on
the show it's really been a lot of fun
well we had Favre on two days ago and he
shot a 79 that was the same day we had
Elway on who said that you know his game
he hasn't played it in a long time but
far Favre says he's beginning to just
beginning to break 80 and Elway Elway
really wouldn't he said he he kind of
just threw away that he was a 1 he
hasn't played in a while he's just a 1
and I was inspired by how he just threw
away the fact that he's a 1 that really
inspired just talk about their John's
one at the moment that's what he said
yeah it was very casual very casual is
what he said but we got Marshall Faulk
on he refuses to say what his handicap
is because he doesn't want to give out
any candy David probably quite right you
know yeah you must know guys like that
well yeah I do you mean I know a bunch
of people you know that couldn't get
done to think of that just as they cut
off a finger but but what yeah what's
yours David what's you what do you play
you know I I haven't people ask me that
all the time I mean how's your game
these days and I haven't played golf in
14 years David I got yeah people say no
I sure I don't I can't my left arm is
crippled I can't close my left hand from
a bicycle accident yeah from a bicycle
accident I got run over by a truck and a
trailer
in Dallas in 2007 I want to say yeah
2007 and it took me a long time for me
for a while I thought I might even lose
the arm so you know there's been no golf
you know since then for me I did I
didn't know that David I don't know I
actually got hit three times by Motor
Vehicles before I quit I woke up in a
hospital in Dearborn Michigan wearing a
turban for some reason you know with a
hole in my head have no recollection of
that accident
all I could hit but a motorist who just
kept on going apparently and then I went
nearly went through a windshield in New
York and that was riding the bike you
know it was starting to look like a
hobby you know an open tab at the ER was
no so I decided I decided against
against that and I haven't had any
exercise since now I know you're kidding
on that but hold on a second so what's
the best round you've ever had then give
me the best round you ever had the best
the best rind I ever shot it was from a
blind hangover and for the Catalan open
in Eastern Spain yeah and I shot 61 that
particular day I played with Alfonso
Pinero sure and he was I threw up on the
third tee come on dear and yeah because
the night before I thought I'd missed a
cut by shot and my pal you know Sam
Torrance and I went out and we had a few
adult beverages yes and you know was one
of those nights where you say I'll have
one more and then I'll stay yeah and
stayed for thirty in the morning and I
just happened to notice on the board at
the hotel we were staying in the draw
she was up and I was off first at 6:30
you know so I went out in 31 came back
in 30 and I honestly can say that at no
stage during the round did I know where
I stood so the following I went from
just making a cut by a shot to being too
behind and that the next evening I
decided well I'd better suck it in here
you know and you know act like an adult
so I did and then I went out and shot 75
the following day so I'm not proud of it
so what's this
what's the moral of the story then David
before I let you go Willie you know I'm
not sure that it would be immoral as
they correct yeah I don't know you know
but but I did to play well when I didn't
feel well okay like jogging in my career
I shot a couple of 62 when another one
actually I was hungover there the second
one not not so much but you know I think
you know feeling ill or whatever took my
mind off you know we're always gonna go
sure you know uh nobody made me relax a
little we recommended I wouldn't
recommend it by the way that wouldn't be
a bad name for a book or your next book
or your memoir David just you know hey
thanks for coming on I always appreciate
it I look forward to our chat I don't
have I don't think any stories nearly as
interesting is the one you just told but
I'll do my best
oh I'm not sure I look forward to
talking to you rich thanks for having my
back at you always always David Feherty
NBC in Golf Channel analyst at Fair twit
on Twitter and Instagram and again check
out up-close Feherty up-close from a
distance available for fans to watch on
Golf Channel's YouTube page with new
interviews being added weekly hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here